at the LES at the 11th hour Lindsey
Graham shows up and speaks a lot of
truth for a lot of people break down how
you see this all playing out so Lindsey
Graham came up he is the backbone of the
GOP now nevertheless this is a this is
hey that's how you know we're living in
the matrix this is a tactical error for
president Trump it was caused by the
moral cowardice of Jeff Flake this is
Luci pulling the football away the FBI
investigation as Joe Biden said it
cannot be conclusive all I can do is ask
the people who were alleged to be there
what happened we have statements from
all of them they all refute Christine
Ford's testimony there it is I did the
FBI investigation for you it's a farce
and it's a charade and it's very unfair
to national that's a great point we're
in the moment of investigations right
now let's investigate everything it's if
you believe in women should be believed
story should be told everyone should be
heard right but on their own terms that
they want to be private should we not go
wall-to-wall in an investigation to find
out who leaked the name of Chrissy Ford
to the media and brought her out in
public when he she wanted to be proud
what a disservice to a woman who wanted
her story told the way she wanted to
tell it would you not and should
Democrats not support that kind of
investing I think some of them would I'm
not sure that all of them would I think
it's a decent question to be asking that
won't be done obviously in the next week
here I think where dr. Ford really did
shine though is batting away that
political operative argument where she
made it clear I sent this letter in when
Judge Cavanaugh was on a list of many
very well-qualified jurists I just
wanted to make years after he was on the
second highest court in the land then a
civic duty do you really think that
she's being used by the Democrats right
now to delay to hit delay the
confirmation at the last moment to
effect the November 6th election and you
know what this is doing energizing
Republicans so with that so let's have
the Democrats are already energized but
you know what how many Democrats will
you call on to say this week when it
comes back there's no proof that this
never happened how many of them will
vote yes that's a really fair point so
what I
one of the things Lindsey Graham said is
say hey that Sonia Sotomayor and Elena
Kagan cuz I voted for him because they
were eminently qualified because Barack
Obama won an election is there any
acknowledgement at all and quickly to
you and then to Michael that elections
have consequences and Cavanaugh's if
this comes back and nothing's there
shouldn't it be a 90/10 vote yeah it
won't be ninety ten but you will I think
at the three senators who voted for Neil
Bohr said so Heidi Heitkamp Joe Donnelly
and Manchin right and it might be I
think that those three would go for a
Donnell Donnelly broke the dam of the
red state Democrats to say we need an
FBI investigation i'ma vote no for this
you might get a couple more in the
spirit of these red state Democrats but
no it's a much more partisan time and
yet people feel like he is a threat to
not only roe v wade by environmental
protection Michael Bay we buried the
lead on this that's what's all that it's
all about Democrats abortion lust it's
what it's been about the entire time yes
but when when it was up to Neil Gorsuch
you wouldn't change the dynamic of the
court they didn't they didn't play as
hard now he will change the dynamic of
the court so they want to delay an extra
week so that some new lunatic can come
out of the woodwork and accuse Brett
Kavanaugh of abducting her up to Planet
Zebulon seven and they're going to have
weeks and weeks and months and months of
more investigations to push through the
midterms all to preserve the fictitious
constitutional right to an abortion